hello we are amy
hi i'm tonya nice to meet you guys hi
i'm moon hi i'm teddy hello i'm ojin
we're av sex and we are here with
buzzfeed to take a quiz to find out
which member of av6 is our bff
you can take the quiz with us by
clicking the link in the description box
below
first question what's the most important
quality you look for in a friend
humor ambition loyalty generosity
honesty trustworthy
trustworthy trustworthy
honesty loyalty how would your friends
describe you
unique brave cute confident dramatic
hilarious
oh unicorn i'm unique
pick the most iconic movie friendship
lion king star wars
spiderman
is your friend this birthday what are
you doing
throwing them a surprise party buying a
last-minute gift
baking them a cake taking them to
karaoke
oh karaoke i like everybody
treating them to a nice dinner buying on
last minute
party surprise party what's your
favorite activity to do with friends
go to a concert work out at the gym
go to the movies play video games share
a meal binge watch a new tv show
play video games go to the movies
and go to a concert which friend are you
and your friend grew in
the baby the baby the responsible one
the flooding one uh the adventurous one
always me the shy one the smart one 100
person two not a smart one
are you sure ah responsible one yeah how
about you
adventurous one gentle baby
i would say i'm the responsible one yeah
you betty
i don't know i have to ask my friends
but i can't right now finally pick an
ab6 about to dance with your friends
free free stay young salute
the answer the answer plans below
hollywood
i think i'm staying breathe
what do you think i think the ansel how
about you blindfold up
flying for love okay
oh my god okay
my bff is in park
uh you're a fiery deeply passionate
person who is determined to achieve
their dreams no matter what
you're also caring and responsible and
will always
go above and beyond for your friends you
and ujin
would bond over your shared love of
dancing and we'll definitely end up
going on a trip to hawaii together one
day how about you
you should be besties with already all
right
you're an adventurer at heart bold
kind-hearted and brave you and tonyan
would absolutely bond over your shared
love of movies
and can likely be found planning
exciting trips together
how about you please you should be best
friends with um
are too pure for this world you have the
natural ability
to see the good in others no matter what
you also make friends
easily with your hilarious jokes and
adorable
mannerisms you and um would definitely
bond over your shared love of cooking
and can likely be found baking delicious
treats together
he sucks at cooking you should be bff
with tewi
you're a true original who is not afraid
to stand up from the rest of the crowd
with your bright personality from
amazing fashion sense
correct you good vision sense and big
dreams there's nothing you can't
accomplish
you and heavy would definitely bond over
your shared similar interests
like your love of girls group dance
especially if they're performed by
somebody and twice
best friends forever thank you buzzfeed
and be sure to check out our new
ep mode complete have a dream and a
title single comma
also known as close bye
you